en este vídeo vamos a ver el estéreo
especificidad de una reacción de
eliminación de dos primero
identifiquemos a nuestro carbono alfa
aquí está el que está unido al halógeno
este es nuestro carbono alfa y nuestro
carbono beta está justo aquí con un
protón beta este es nuestro protón beta
esta vez sólo hay un protón en la
posición beta por lo que sólo
obtendremos la proyección de newman y
sólo será posible un estero y somero
para esta reacción es diferente al vídeo
anterior en donde vimos dos posibles
protones en la posición beta que nos
daban dos con formaciones distintas lo
que formaba dos productos diferentes y
uno de los esteros o meros era más
favorecido pero en este caso sólo
obtendremos un producto
veamos el enlace alfa beta desde arriba
pondré un ojo por aquí y al observar el
carbono alfa beta desde aquí tratemos de
dibujar la proyección de newman
empecemos con este carbono aquí hay un
grupo metilo del lado derecho
así que nos queda por acá y luego este
hidrógeno nos queda del lado izquierdo
y por acá está el anillo de benceno
vamos a llamarle grupo fenil o
que se abrevia como ph
entonces en lugar de dibujar todo el
anillo solo ponemos el grupo fenil o ph
muy bien
el carbono de atrás que en este caso es
nuestro carbono alfa lo vamos a
representar con un círculo
y tenemos un grupo fenil o hacia arriba
desde donde estamos viendo la molécula
para esto pueden usar su modelo si lo
necesitan que más tenemos por aquí
tenemos un bromo a la derecha justo aquí
y finalmente hay un hidrógeno a la
izquierda aquí nos queda nuestra
proyección de newman y como en el vídeo
anterior necesitamos ver desde otro
punto de vista para poder saber cómo es
el mecanismo quiero que pongamos este
protón hasta arriba que el hidrógeno nos
quede arriba
y el bromo lo pasamos hacia abajo
una vez más como en el vídeo anterior de
dibujar en la proyección de newman no
voy a rotar ningún enlace solo estoy
cambiando el punto de vista
pongamos esto hacia arriba el hidrógeno
está arriba en esta proyección de newman
y claro el hidrógeno está conectado a
este carbono que nos queda del lado
derecho
bueno este grupo metilo el grupo metilo
nos queda a la derecha y tenemos un
grupo fenil o del lado izquierdo no he
cambiado nada
un grupo fenil o nos queda del lado
izquierdo muy bien qué más tenemos
necesitamos dibujar el carbono de atrás
ok
representamos el carbono de atrás con
este círculo ahora que está unido a
nuestro carbono bueno entre el hidrógeno
y el metil se encuentra el otro grupo
fenil o se observan aquí entre el
hidrógeno y el grupo metilo está un
grupo fenil entonces nos queda por acá y
luego el bromo que está abajo justo como
lo queremos aquí está el bromo aún nos
falta algo claro el nitrógeno
así nos queda nuestra proyección de
newman podemos usar esta proyección pero
algunas veces es mejor también dibujar
la proyección de caballete dibujemos
nuestra proyección de caballete vamos a
ver nuestro carbono de adelante nos
quedaría así y el carbono de atrás nos
queda como una y así en el carbono de
adelante hay un hidrógeno justo aquí por
aquí hay un grupo fenil y por acá está
el grupo metilo ahora para el carbono de
atrás aquí tenemos un hidrógeno a la
derecha está un grupo fenil y el bromo
nos quedó abajo ya tenemos nuestra
proyección de caballete y nuestra
proyección de newman estamos listos para
dibujar nuestro producto final sabemos
que nuestra base en el mecanismo es el
stock sido de sodio entonces nuestra
base tomará al protón anti peri plan ar
identifiquemos a nuestro protón anti
peri planner si observamos nuestra
proyección de newman el protón anti peri
planar vamos a ver si aquí está el bromo
nuestro protón tiene que estar en el
mismo plano que el bromo así que es este
de aquí muy bien este es el protón que
la base tomará entonces en el mecanismo
podemos poner a nuestra base tomando a
este protón lo que significa que estos
electrones se moverán para formar el
doble enlace y al mismo tiempo estos
electrones se irán con el bromo que es
nuestro grupo saliente si queremos
dibujar el producto de esta reacción
necesitamos pensar en donde se forma el
doble enlace para así saber cómo nos
queda
creo que es más fácil si usamos la
proyección de newman porque así podemos
ver que este grupo fenil o está del lado
opuesto al otro el doble enlace se
formará entre este carbono y este carbón
así que el doble enlace se forma entre
estos dos y el grupo fenil o se
encuentra en lados contrarios por eso
creo que es más fácil si usamos la
proyección de newman que la de caballete
aunque la de caballete también nos sirve
los grupos feng y los stand de lados
contrarios tal vez sea más fácil porque
este hidrógeno está del lado contrario
al grupo metilo así que otra forma de
verlo es que este hidrógeno de aquí está
del lado contrario al grupo metilo así
es más fácil dibujar nuestros productos
vamos a dibujarlos
aquí se forma nuestro doble enlace y
sabemos que el hidrógeno está del lado
contrario al grupo metilo
también sabemos que los grupos fenil
están en lados contrarios al doble
enlace así que nos queda uno de los
esteros o meros que en realidad es el
único que se forma porque sólo tenemos
un protón beta que esther y somero es
bueno aprendimos a identificar esto en
los vídeos anteriores si observamos el
carbono de la izquierda este carbono
asignemos la prioridad basándonos en el
aumento de los números atómicos
nuestro grupo fenil es el número uno y
el grupo metilo es el número dos ahora
vamos con este carbono
el grupo fenil tiene una prioridad más
alta que el hidrógeno entonces cuando
dibujamos nuestra línea punteada podemos
ver que los grupos de mayor prioridad
están en lados contrarios al doble
enlace entonces tenemos el estero y
somero
en esta reacción sólo se puede formar el
estero y somero y no podemos obtener el
estéril somero z por eso esta reacción
es estéreo específica